una estudiante muestra los siguientes
pasos como solución de la siguiente
ecuación pero su respuesta es incorrecta
tenemos esta ecuación logaritmo base 5
de 2x al cuadrado menos 3 x 1 menos el
logaritmo base 5 de x menos 1 más el
organismo base 5 de 125 todo esto igual
a 6 aquí están los pasos que desarrolló
el alumno aquí son los pasos que
desarrolló el estudiante nos preguntan
en qué paso cometió el primer error
veamos aquí en este paso lo que hizo el
estudiante fue tomar esto
y factorizar lo dejándolo así esta
factorización está bien nosotros vemos
que 2x menos 1 por x1 es igual 2x por x
2 x es igual a 2x cuadrada 2 x menos 1 -
2 x menos 1 por x x menos 1 por menos
uno es más 1 y esto es 2 x al cuadrado
menos 3 x más son lo que vemos que es lo
mismo que está aquí entre paréntesis así
que la factorización estuvo bien este
primer paso está correcto
ahora aquí de el primero el segundo paso
conservó este menos logaritmo de x 1 y
lo que hizo fue restar 3 en ambos lados
de la ecuación lo que también está bien
en ese tercer paso lo que quiso hacer el
alumno es restar dos logaritmos con la
misma base que es lo mismo que
dividirlos su lógica es que si yo tengo
un logaritmo
2 x 1
x x 1
menos el logaritmo de x menos uno x uno
ahorita estoy omitiendo la base para
notar darme tanto esto es lo mismo que
tener el logaritmo
esto es igual al logaritmo de 2 x 1 por
x 1
/
x1
error por lo que veo aquí es que si
nosotros vemos se anulan estos términos
de acá y nos querer nos quedaría 2x
menos 1 pero aquí dejo el término que no
no es correcto entonces aquí es donde
está el error se equivocó en el paso 3
que es la opción c veamos el siguiente
problema
cierto elemento radioactivo decae en
cierto tiempo de acuerdo a la ecuación e
iguala a por un medio elevado a t entre
300 donde es el número de gramos
presentes inicialmente y t es el tiempo
en años si se tienen mil gramos
inicialmente cuántos gramos quedarán
después de 900 años bueno pues
simplemente vamos a sustituir estos
valores en la ecuación mi ecuaciones ya
iguala y nos dicen que es el número de
gramos presentes y son 1000 gramos
inicialmente
por un medio elevado al at&t es el
tiempo 900 años
900 entre 300
ok vamos a comenzar simplificando este
exponente quitamos estos ceros y esto es
lo mismo que tener 1000 por un medio
elevado a nueve tercios todavía podemos
simplificar lo más esto es igual a 1000
por un medio elevado a la 39 entre 33
y esto me va a quedar que es un medio
elevado al cubo va a ser igual a un
octavo así que esto es igual a 1000
entre 8 y cuánto es 1000 entre 8 es 125
así que van a crear 125 gramos después
de 900 años y esta es la opción c veamos
el siguiente problema
número 51
bacterias en un cultivo crecen
exponencialmente con el tiempo como se
muestra en la siguiente tabla en esta
tabla nos preguntan cuál de las
ecuaciones expresa el número de
bacterias
presentes en cualquier tiempo de
crecimiento exponencial significa que si
bien son mis bacterias tengo mi cantidad
inicial a lleva a ser igual a mi
cantidad inicial multiplicado por algún
número que tiene un factor exponente que
indica que tan rápido crece o decrece a
algo así que va a ser multiplicado por
un número que tiene un exponente con una
constante y mi variable que va a ser en
este caso te de tiempo aquí inventé mi
variable x elevada alguna constante por
el tiempo esta es la forma general del
crecimiento o decremento exponencial
aunque quizás lo vean con otras letras
esta es la idea general
la tabla vemos que las bacterias se
duplican cada día lo que nos dice que
tendremos alguna potencia de 2 así que
va a ser el número de bacterias igual a
la cantidad inicial por 2
^ el tiempo en el día cero tenemos la
cantidad inicial entonces si sustituyó t
aquí y mi cantidad inicial de 100
tendréis igual a 100
en este caso en el 1000 esto se vuelve
uno y me queda 100 me queda mi cantidad
inicial de bacterias
de igual a 1 lleva a ser igual a 100 por
2 a la 1
esto es un x se me estaba olvidando
poner esto
2 a la 1 es 2 100 por 2 son 200 y en el
día 1 es 200 y en el día cero son 100 y
en el día 2 es igual a 100 por 2 elevado
al cuadrado que es igual 2 por 2
44 por 100 400 así que en mi segundo día
son 400 bacterias esta es la ecuación
que me representa este crecimiento
exponencial que es mi opción b
veamos el siguiente problema
el número 52
si en la ecuación igualados a la x se
grafica cuál de los siguientes valores
de x nos dará el punto más cercano al
eje x
de graficar esto vamos a dejar nuestros
ejes para los bonitos
así
qué será
- ok vamos a sustituir los valores este
es mi eje x este es mi eje y
para x igual a 0 2 al acero va a ser
igual a 1 así que si este es un 1 mi
punto cuando x igual a cero me lleva a
valer uno va a estar acá para x igual a
1 2 a la 1 es 2 así que mi punto si esto
es el que es 2 va a estar por acá más o
menos
si yo sustituyó en x igual a 2
2 x 2 es igual a 4 así que me quedara
este es un 4 el punto me va a quedar más
o menos
por aquí
una forma
de la gráfica más o menos así ok esto es
para los valores positivos de x
qué pasa si vemos las potencias
negativas si yo pongo sustituyó menos 1
aquí va a ser un medio entonces si este
x es menos 1
lleva a ser igual a un medio estará por
acá
así que el punto va a estar aquí
si yo sustituyó en la ecuación x menos
22 al menos 2 va a ser igual a 1 entre 2
al cuadrado 1 entre 4 va a ser algo más
chico que un medio así que va a estar
más o menos por aquí de manera que
nuestra gráfica
va a estar así acercándose cada vez más
a cero pero sin tocar aunque ve aquí que
en mis opciones no tengo ninguna
negativa por lo que la más pequeña de
estas opciones es la que nos va a
generar el punto más cercano al eje x
veamos tres cuartos es mayor que un
cuarto cinco tercios es mayor que un
cuarto ocho tercios es mayor que un
cuarto así que la respuesta correcta va
a ser mi opción a un cuarto